faites vous ce soir qui ça monsieur
personnes se disaient il fait doux
vous n'avez jamais essayé de mettre un
nom sur ce qui l'obsède ans monsieur sy
mais il vend il va pleuvoir
il fait beau comme été vosges actifs ce
n'est qu'une histoire de grammaire
française
non monsieur le dernier le plus
pernicieuse
il était une fois il commence toujours
les histoires mais seulement quand tout
est fini
[Musique]
rêver dès la semaine elle n'a rien fait
n'est plus pas vraiment belle
c'est mieux elle est faite pour moi
doucet
juste pour mot
je les ai rêvé si fort
[Musique]
que les draps s'en souviennent
e
je te remets dans son corps
merci
je t'aime
si je
là
l'espoir
on est témoin
ce soir
une nuit juste pour elle et moi
et de me
non
[Musique]
j'ai encore rêvé d'elle
pour ça
pas vraiment belle mois
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
à
six mois
une nuit
juste
voilà
c'est moi
vim
je n'ai
tout seul
richard dewitte bonsoir alors tu es le
riton du groupe
il était une fois mais pourquoi riton
parce que quand on s'appelle richard
c'est que ça voilà quinze ans pour mapa
pierrick naud ça fait 15 ans qu'on tape
appelé riches et pauvres et je le sais
je sais taïwan ont tué le batteur de il
était une fois j'ai testé le batteur oui
dans cette chanson est sortie en quelle
année
angers enfin révélé à 75 75 et comment
s'est passée la création de cette
chanson elle s'est passé très rapidement
c'est une des musiques que j'ai mis le
moins de temps à composer
j'ai dû mettre une heure ou quelque
chose comme ça et puis le texte est lui
aussi très vite c'est serge pollen qui
fait qu'ils aient tous les textes sur un
coin de table boom krak souvient dans
quelle circonstance qu'il a écrite la
musique
je me souviens de l'endroit où je les
fait ouais c'était lorraine à l'époque
j'avais été un petit studio à courbevoie
et dans le placard à balais j'avais
aménagé un petit studio d'enregistrement
encore en train des cartons à eux ça et
je décompose et la nuit comme ça comme
ça ouais c'est tombé du ciel quoi et tu
savais en l'écrivant tu avais le
sentiment que tu avais fait un truc bien
où c'était une chanson de plus - là
c'était trop lyrique et en plus quand on
album est sorti avec cette chanson dans
le tas la maison de disques et nous
avons pensé que c'était
c'était pas un tube façon il n'y avait
pas de refrain c'était pas pour être
honnête c'était trop lyrique
personne n'y croyait en fait
effectivement alors l'album est sorti
comme ça avec une autre chanson en
promotion numéro 1 sur l'album et c'est
les médias qui nous ont dit mais vous
êtes fous là vous avez une chanson tube
dix fois plus fin que voilà et puis on a
recommencé la promotion / 10 / j'ai
encore rêvé d'elle et c'est vrai
qu'entre vous vous l'appeliez j'ai
encore des bretzels
ouais ouais
alors il y avait un cas ciel c'était
rien qu'un steak way vient faire un tour
sur l'ampli au lieu de venir à tour sous
la pluie c'est qu'elle le dit et c'est
alors il était une fois c'était cinq
garçons cinq garçons et une fille mais
d'abord les cinq garçons c'était quoi
vous juillet que polnareff c'est ça non
sert serge qui était le parolier du
groupe
lui et moi on est des amis d'enfance
sétois due à l'âge de 5 ans on a
on a commencé à faire de la musique à
l'âge de 15 ans environ dans les
premiers groupes on s'est appelé tour à
tour les beatles et un vrai pays de l
est les français des étudiants les
beatles en règle du beatles
je sais qu'à l'époque je veux défriser
les cheveux je mettais des bacs pour
rassembler ringo et ensuite on a changé
le nom m'a filé rythm and blues l'on
sait a plaidé jelly roll on a toujours
été ensemble tous les deux on accompagne
et un tas de gens on l'a été avec trenet
avec henri salvador avec polnareff
pendant deux ans et demi et puis
parallèlement à ça on a fait plein de
groupes qui ont changé de nom très
souvent et puis un jour on a décidé de
faire un dernier groupe
on avait arrêté polnareff parce qu'il
était malade bon et puis on se dit bon
on verra bien quoi c'est le groupe de la
dernière chance à terme en moi je vais
plus j'en avais un peu
ras-le-bol et joël comment vous l'avez
rencontrée alors joël c'était à l'époque
où serge et moi on accompagne et
polnareff donc on michel donner un gala
à port grimaud ce jour là il nous avait
prêté sa mustang blanche décapotable et
on était parti faire une en vadrouille
sur le port de saint-tropez
et puis à la terrasse du gorille parmi
les clients il y avait joël et sa soeur
qui était là j'étais tout jeune tous les
deux et puis bon si c'est ça et puis et
puis serge et joël donc sympathisé plus
que jusqu'à les emprunts et voilà la i10
a commencé ici alors comment s'est
terminée tout ça un jour c'est vrai que
c'est la rupture entre entre serge et
joël qui a commencé c'est pas vraiment
ça sert qu'on était contourné énormément
on avait en moyenne dans à partir de 75
française jusqu'à la fin genre 200 gala
part en tournée sur tournée c'est bon
rentrer à paris on avait juste le temps
de faire des photos des td de composer
de nouvelles chansons et on était 24
heures sur 24 ensemble et puis
on était quelques uns en groupe à avoir
envie de faire autre chose un petit peu
doit se prendre une année sabbatique
quoi bon le manque d'intelligence de
certains quoi je pense qu'il faut voir
plus loin moi j'aurais bien aimé qu'on
soit les compagnons de la chanson que
dans 19 en 2020 en soir voir la fin des
stagiaires un peu mais et puis c'était
possible il y avait trop de dissensions
entre nous et il y en avait qui a failli
faire du rock'n'roll d'autres qui
avaient envie de chanter seul essai un
peu compréhensible et à un moment vous
êtes tous partis vers des vers des
carrières solo c'est ça absolument pas
aussi bah oui moi depuis 80 j'ai fait
tout de suite un album qui est sorti
qu'il ya eu comme on dit a succédé steam
qui a bien marché au québec mais en
france ça n'a pas été le pied en quelle
année ça s'est arrêté il était une fois
enfin 79 vue voilà donc quand joël est
morte en 82 ça faisait trois ans et est
actuellement
ça fait dix ans qu'elle est mort d'un
arrêt cardiaque dû à une overdose
est ce que est ce que toi tu savais ça
tu savais qu est-ce que des français non
non non parce que à l'époque où j'étais
avec vous tu n'avais jamais eu ce
sentiment non bon les pétards des trucs
comme ça mais bon sincèrement je savais
pas et puis pendant ce des trois ans
avant sa mort moi je vende à des traits
plus de rapports on se téléphone être
très peu c'est dommage d'ailleurs on va
toujours après l'été ou quand on a
appris ça j'étais chez moi
et je peux le site et c'était européen
qui m'a appelé un matin en me disant
écoutez voilà on a une information
faucon là faut qu'on nous l'a confirmé
si on vous appelle vers 13 heures
pendant leurs deux europes midi pardon
c'est que la nouvelle est confirmée
malheureusement il m'explique le truc
alors là je suis tombé par terre ça fait
c'est un choc terrible et ils m'ont
rappelé malheureusement à 13 heures ça
fait très très
très bizarre est-ce que tu as souffert
de ce changement de situation ses aveux
passés d'une star itude absolument total
1 espèce d'un anonyme améliorée au tout
début oui parce qu'on s'imagine pas
quand on a systématiquement un disque
qui sort et on s'est systématiquement
entre alors dans tous les domaines dont
on prend des mauvaises habitudes
attends je comprends pas génial on va
faire un album on amis on s'est donné un
mal fou j'ai déjà vais début c'étaient
des belles chansons dont je faisais et
je comprenais pas que ce soit le flop et
au fil de talent et je suis habitué je
me suis débrouillé j'ai fait d'autres
choses
j'ai fait des chansons pour enfants des
disques des les indicatifs pour la télé
des coeurs là c'est vraiment parce que
je diversifie mes activités je fais un
tas de choses
est ce que tu crois que il était une
fois être un grand groupe
où vous avez été un grand oui oui
absolument je répète un très grand
groupe si on avait gardé le même état
d'esprit que dans les cinq premières
années oui absolument
quelque chose il y avait une magie un
truc on se comprenait tout de suite en
arrivant au studio je sais pas enfin si
on avait la foi
déjà c'est vrai ça fait il est d'une
fois mais bon j'avais un feeling huawei
vite ça s'est un peu dégradée bon tu
regrettes ah bah oui c'est sûr ça s'est
passé à côté d'un truc énorme
non c'est même pas ça c'est que c'est ma
plus belle aventure de musiciens c'était
une fois de ma vie musiciens ça fait un
paquet d'années que je fais ça c'est
vrai on sait quelque chose elle le 46
ans ces papiers disons cruellement mais
disons d'avoir ton avenir derrière toi
non non non parce que c'est des choses
que j'ai faites
je n'ai pas derrière moi il était avec
moi toujours un puis c'est pour finir je
suis pas encore gâteau je pense
cavalaire alors dit moi j'ai un album
qui sort et son secteur voilà alors on
va parler de 2,10 d'avoir une compile de
il était une fois qui s'appelle comment
je serai génial appelle les plus belles
fois c'est joli c'est bien trouvé ça
c'est une idée de hizb i gotta imai 1
nous on les a mais si on nous a mis sur
le fait accompli très bonne surprise
puisque on pensait pas que ça marche
très très bien sa foi disque d'or
étonnant hein c'est étonnant et ton
album alors alors mon album moi j'ai mis
une bonne année et demi enregistré parce
qu'on ne veut pas faire n'importe quoi
avec un producteur indépendant
ça va sortir on a retardé un peu la
sortie à cause il était une fois il s'en
sortir en octobre puis on verra bien
quoi je veux dire si ça marche tant
mieux
et si ça marche pas tu enfin ces puits
alors c'est une profession de foi je
veux dire c'est s'est massé ma passion
c'est ma vie si je peux pas vivre sans
bon musicaux complètement n'y a pas de
rente à ça alors et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux